hi I'm Stevo and this is the wired auto
complete interview
[Music]
was Stevo in a band you could say Jack
Jack was a band a band of
it's
rad now it's been a while since I
Googled myself so this could be a
complete shock where is Stevo from I
grew up in five different countries if
you can believe it I was born in England
moved to Brazil when I was six months
old moved to Connecticut when I was four
to Florida when I was six to England
when I was nine to Canada when I was 12.
back to England when I was 13 then I
really started traveling is Stevo teeth
real well
those ones are really gone the rest of
them have fake stuff mounted on they're
there they just have crowns and veneers
is Stevo married I'm not married but I
am engaged and I wear this ring as a
sign of respect because let's face it
what's wrong with our society that only
women should indicate that they're taken
is the idea that men should just go and
do whatever they want now I'm taking
silly me I missed one how is Stevo
how is Stevo
I think I'm doing pretty well my tour is
going really well my relationship is
good I'm still clean and sober I'm in
good health I overall I'd say things are
going great thanks for asking is Stevo
retired nope I'm not retired I have
recently decided to retire from doing
backflips of course I am planning a
farewell backflip I don't want to swim
with sharks anymore I think I can safely
say I'm retired from swimming with
sharks all right looks like we're done
with that one
what is Stevo's real name it's Stephen
spell it the pH middle name Gilchrist
last name Glover what college did Stevo
go to now not only did I go to Ringling
Brothers Barnum and Bailey clown college
I graduated from it making me the only
college graduate on the cast of Jackass
what is
Stevo's bucket list tour it's a
multimedia Comedy Tour where I screen
footage of stunts I never would have
been allowed to do for Jackass because a
lot of them are flagrantly illegal and
some of it's actually x-rated what did
Stevo's dad do my dad was a wildly
successful corporate businessman he was
the president of Pepsi Cola in all of
Brazil he went from Pepsi to RJ Reynolds
to back go and then after that he went
on to become the president of Nabisco
International so if you think about it
soda cigarettes and cookies
he's going to hell
what happened to Stevo oh that's sad
what happened to Stevo I mean Where Do
We Begin what hasn't happened to Stephen
okay good so we'll continue
did Stevo open an animal sanctuary
nobody you can bet your butt I'm gonna I
was recently in Memphis and I visited
Graceland and I thought oh god I've got
to hurry up and get this animal
sanctuary going so I can have my own
little Stevo museum with all the animals
oh dude it's gonna be great how did
Stevo and Johnny Knoxville meet we were
introduced by a skateboarding magazine
called Big Brother which was
particularly naughty and filled with all
kinds of stuff that had nothing to do
with skateboarding like me and Johnny
Knoxville
how hot is Stevo's hot sauce it depends
on which one because I have two there's
the OG Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole which is really just delicious
not overly hot but then there's the new
unbelievably hot Stevo's butthole
Destroyer hot sauce the Destroyer is
really hot I don't know the Scoville of
the butthole Destroyer hot sauce but I
do know that the three top ingredients
listed are the three hottest peppers on
Earth scorpion ghost and Carolina Reaper
what happened to Stevo's voice see this
is a big one I thought maybe I had
something going on with my vocal cords
so I went into this voice doctor and he
said that there's actually nothing wrong
with me whatsoever I'm just using like
the muscles above my vocal cords I was
like seriously doc you're telling me I
just suck at talking talking I've gone
back and forth about it I hired a vocal
coach part of me thinks it's just
trademark you know a lot of people have
said dude your voice is who you are a
lot of other people think it's like
listening to a cement grinder how is
Stevo still alive
I wonder that every day no idea
does Stevo do meet and greets I do I
toured comedy clubs tirelessly for 11
years and after every show in the comedy
club I did a meet and greet with the
entire audience but since then I've
graduated to Big theaters and so now
it's like a thousand people every night
and I just can't meet that many people
it's a limited meet and greet now does
Stevo skate you bet your gosh dang darn
butt I do been skating like crazy lately
ripping in fact to be clear skateboard
and that rollerblading crap does Stevo
speak Spanish I spoke my first words in
Portuguese I spoke fluent Spanish in
nursery school so I learned three
languages by the age of three and forgot
two of them completely by the age of
five which might make you think I'm an
idiot but apparently when you learn
multiple languages as a toddler you
develop more of your brain
said sort of a win and a fail does Stevo
still have his back tattoo no way I'm
partnering with this thing
get out of here that's the thing about
tattoos they tend to stick around now
there are tattoos that did get removed I
had the words [ __ ] and [ __ ] on my
knuckles I kept it that way for over 10
years very proud of how I just skated
through life without that really
negatively impacting my livelihood But
ultimately I felt it outlived its
usefulness and I got those profane words
removed lasered off but the bag tattoo
not going anywhere all right
was Stevo in the circus I was after
graduating from Ringling Brothers and
Barnum and Bailey clown college I did
not go to the Ringling Brothers Barnum
and Billy circus but I did get employed
by this circus in a flea market in Fort
Lauderdale Florida it was called the
Hannaford Family Circus and I worked
there for six months right up until the
day I started shooting the jackass
Series yeah it's crazy I washed my clown
makeup off for the last time and within
a half an hour I was barfing up a
goldfish into a fishbowl and the rest is
history so to speak was Stevo in a band
you could say jackass was a band a band
of idiots but when I was a kid I really
loved the band Motley Crew so much that
when they came to my town I called every
hotel in the Yellow Pages asking for a
room by the name of their manager after
hours I got through and the manager's
brother answered the phone he was so
impressed by my initiative I got on the
list for backstage passes and had my
photo taken with Tommy Lee and Nikki
Sixx on October 25th of 1987. it's
amazing was Stevo
on Dancing With the Stars I was it was a
fairly traumatic experience for me I was
just terrible at dancing and it was on
live TV and I was newly sober still
super uncomfortable in my own skin I was
just afraid ball of nerves and I lasted
six weeks which just made my misery
prolonged all right
Stevo yoga nah and here's the sad thing
I've tried yoga it's just misery for me
I can't stand it but my body's begging
for yoga I really should do it now one
thing I do do is meditate I actually
keep track of it on an app as of today I
have maintained an average of over 40
minutes of meditation every single day
for
956 straight days I'm creeping up on
three years of a meditation practice and
I have an unshakable faith that it
causes the universe to conspire in my
favor
Stevo Firestone yeah that was a bad one
I mean there's been a number of fire
stunts that went pretty bad for me but
the really bad one ended in skin graft
surgery on 15 of my body where I had the
Flesh of seven different dead people
grafted onto me one little piece
actually became part of me right there
okay Stevo
cauliflower ear that's a good one I've
been trying for the longest time I've
Had The Who's Who of the UFC Hall of
Fame Chuck Liddell John Jones Ronda
Rousey the BMF champ Jorge Mazda doll
everyone's been trying their butts off
to give me cauliflower ear and my ears
just won't have it Steve-O biography
book my first book was called
professional idiot a memoir it was a New
York Times bestseller arguably my
proudest work but my new book comes out
on September 27th it's called A Hard
kick in the nuts what I've learned from
a lifetime of terrible decisions in my
new book I get uncomfortably candid
about my experience with sex addiction
you'd think that giving up drugs and
alcohol would make your life manageable
but in my case I just found other ways
to be completely nuts and Stevo yearbook
quote wow it's an interesting one my
senior quote in the high school year
book it's harder to go up a hill than
down but the view is far better from the
top don't be a slouch put in the work do
something to be proud of how about that
coming from a kid that was just
hopelessly addicted to drugs and alcohol
in high school I think that Googling
oneself is a dangerous activity but in
the grand scheme of things I think that
I get off pretty easy that's it for the
wired auto complete interview and thank
you everybody for watching
subscribe to the channel hit the Bell
leave a comment come on be cool
[Music]